sporting down and
you know the emotional roller coaster
that are these these games the last
couple weeks but we keep winning and
having fun with these guys that's all
that matters i just wanna play and win
for them we didn't do what we wanted to
do today we didn't control the ball like
you said we didn't convert on third
downs a lot but
we found a way to win we just gotta we
gotta stop making it
um you know stop playing so ugly on
offense but it's a good team i don't
care what the record says i was talking
to al afterwards and said that might be
the best pass rush defense and stuff
that they got after today so give them a
lot of credit jerry dulac
hey ben i know the situation you're down
13 nothing kind of dictates uh as such
when your running game is struggling
like that i mean you get to the point
where you figure
hey i got i got to go out and do this
and throw the one and and take matters
into your own hand do you feel that way
at all
um you know what there was you know some
situations uh into the first half
obviously it's kind of a two minute
drive so you're going with a no huddle
tight feel
second half
after the first drive i think we went
three and out
we went to that same package we went to
last week that kind of um
four wides and a tight end and um just
kind of said listen let's let's just go
to work and
the line blocked and i'm just like i
said i can't i can't say enough about
the skill guys the way that they're able
to
do things on the fly and the line
blocking and i'm just really proud of
everybody
we got a group
that sticks together man a group that's
that's mentally tough and is able to
persevere and i'm thankful for that um
but obviously we can't keep having these
conversations every week
because one of these weeks we'll be
doing it with an l if we're not careful
[Music]
it is amazing the steelers have gotten
to 8-0 with very few blowout victories
the win over the browns 38-7 the only
one that stands out every other game
could have gone the other way and they
just keep winning
the team has never been 8-0 in franchise
history they are now it was not easy
yesterday and it felt for a while like
the cowboys were going to win the game
and and you just can't have that when
you're a team as good as the steelers
and you're playing a team that is that
bad in the cowboys and garrett gilbert
is their quarterback garrett gilbert all
due respect are you kidding me garrett
gilbert they let that team hang around
as long as they did they only win by
five points
that that's
that's not encouraging but at the same
time they got the win that's all that
matters they got the win no i i get it
but i i think the the lesson is is like
what mike tomlin said we can't keep like
flirting with danger this way you know
they've let too many teams that are not
on their level
hang around they don't put them away you
know what i understand listen you come
off some big wins there's going to be
some letdowns in the nfl and you're
playing another team that is as
desperate as can be they do have some
good football players on there and the
coaching staff's motivated because it's
all bad it's so yeah that's that's life
in the nfl pittsburgh was asleep i don't
know the way to say it i mean dallas
kind of dominated the line of scrimmage
and was able to run the ball they kind
of dink and dunked with the pass game on
the pittsburgh defense but you know
ultimately pittsburgh's defense made a
few plays in the game
got them the turnover before the half
got the turnovers in the end zone you
know did some of that and slowly big ben
in the passing game figured out how to
attack dallas that's the problem with
pittsburgh too mike and these type of
games they can't run the football so
they can never dominate the line of
scrimmage and do play action passes or
anything like that and it's hard for
them to put teams away or control teams
because of that aspect
one thing to keep an eye on ben
roethlisberger left the game for a short
period of time with a knee injury so as
the week unfolds let's watch the injury
report and let's see if there may be a
bigger issue there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports